here we are in almost detroit yes  i love it here i always say people talk  about detroit like a guy who just lost  his boner like hey i swear to god it's  coming back  you just wait and see  nice town it's cute out there all right  i feel like i did the whole town you  know i had a coney island dog i got  drunk i'm addicted to opioids i love it  here  thanks for coming on to pandemic  some people like to brag they have yeah  you know i never got covered all right  well not getting covets like not getting  hpv sure it's impressive but you also  might be a loser  come on  now we got a new variant the omnichrom  whoa  you know i looked it up there's also a  cryptocurrency called omnichrome it's  weird it's a variant and a  cryptocurrency which makes sense because  they're kind of similar you know i don't  understand either one the government's  trying to control both and my uncle is  never gonna buy it  i love you the best